Manin qui a pris la parole à la suite du
drame survenu à haras ce vendredi euh et
beaucoup euh ont demandé au ministre
pourquoi l'auteur présumé des faits n'a
pas été expulsé il s'est justifié et il
a montré que c'était pas lui le
responsable et il j'ai l'impression
qu'il a un peu passé la balle à Éric
Dupont Moretti ministre de la Justice
regardez il y a 4000 étrangers
délinquant que je ne peux pas expulser
du territoire national alors même que je
le veux parce que la loi empêche de les
expulser soit parce qu'ils sont mariés
en France soit parce qu'ils ont eu des
enfants en France soit parce qu'ils sont
arrivés avant l' de 13 ans sur le
territoire de la République quand bien
même ils auraient commis leur acte après
18 ans alors euh donc a priori g et
Jacques il voilà il dit que c'est pas
c'est pas de son fait hein non c'est
c'est assez complexe hein en fait il
aaurait pu être expulsé si sa loi qu'il
prévoit avait été votée mais il y a a
quand même des exceptions qui font que
peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas non plus
été expulsé en fait si sa loi était
passée il aurait été sous le coup d'une
OQTF mais il n'aura pas été expulsé
définitivement ça c'est voilà donc c'est
pour ça aussi qu'il prend la parole en
disant bah si MAOI passe on limitera un
certain nombre peut-être d'exaction en
tous les cas on pourra permettre un plus
grand nombre d'expulsion alors la France
est passé en alerte urgence attentat
après l'attaque mortelle au couteau
survenu ce vendredi dans un lycée d'
race on vous en a parlé vendredi bien
entendu le niveau le le plus élevé du
dispositif Vig pirate et c'est vrai
qu'on a on a tous peur he pour nos
enfants actuellement un dispositif de
sécurité renforcé a donc été mis en
place dans toute la France un dispositif
qui rassure certains cependant il y a
une question que les parents se posent
suite à ce drame nos enfants sont-ils en
sécurité dans leurs écoles que faut-il
mettre en place les annonces de Gabriel
Atal bah vous allez les voir là et on en
parle après regardez des policiers aux
portes des lycées et des collèges dès
cet après-midi des patrouilles ont été
déployé devant certains établissement
scolaire ici à Paris certains parents
regrettent que cette présence ne soit
pas systématique avec cette attaque se
repose la question de la sécurité des
établissements ces dernières années dans
certains lycées des boîtiers d'alarme
reliés à la police ont été installés en
cas d'intrusion dans d'autres des
caméras de vidéosurveillance filment la
cour les entrées et les sorties des
élèves des tourniqués des sasses de
sécurité ont été mis en place mais tous
ces systèmes ne sont pas infailli
alors déjà c'est très bien que gabrielal
prenne ça à bras le cor et propose des
mesures mais très franchement sir je
pense qu'il faut être honnête c'est
impossible de sanctuariser tous les
établissements scolaires vous pouvez
mettre des vigiles qui va payer comment
on va faire des policiers c'est pas
vraiment leur boulot des Sass et des
portiques mais vous imaginez 1200 élèves
à 8h du matin devant des SAS des
portiques de sécurité c'est impossible
donc peut-être que les caméras mais les
caméras c'est en général pour l'après
donc c'est vraiment très compliqué voilà
honnêtement moi je vous le dis j'ai j'ai
une fille dans un établissement scolaire
très bien j'ai peur parce qu'on se rend
compte que n'importe qui peut entrer
dans une école hélas oui sécurisé au
maximum c'est pas la solution là on l'a
dit c'est pas infaillible à 100 % la
vraie question c'est pourquoi ces mecsl
sont encore en France alors qu'on savait
que potentiellement c'était des
terroristes et qu'ils étaient fichers S
c'est ça qu'il faut régler parce que
c'est pas en mettant de la sécurité à
chaque école qu'on va éviter ce type
d'événement tragique malheureusement
d'autant que on le voit dans toutes les
affaires c'est que les signalements ont
eu lieu c'est pas comme si on
oui Chac j'ai pas compris on m'a parlé
d'une histoire ce weekend comme quoi
cette personne devait être expulsée et
que finalement il n'a pas été il y a
quelques années sa famille habité à Renn
et des associations a fait en sorte
qu'il rest effectivement ça remonte je
crois à 2014 de mémoire mais il y a eu
plusieurs associations
euh communist don le Parti communiste
qui ont manifesté en fait c'est au
moment où la famille était sous le coup
d'une expulsion et ils se sont un
certain nombre d'associations protester
contre ça et du coup c'est seul le père
a été expulsé mais pas le restant de la
de la famille et parce qu'il faut dire
que c'était en pleine affaire leonarda à
l'époque donc il y avait un traumatisme
leonarda et comme il était il était
scolarisé qu'il était arrivé sur le
territoire avant ses 13 ans l'exécutif a
dit un peu pas de vague voilà on va pas
aller Françis Hollande à l'épo fr
hollandeuelmanuel Val à l'intérieur
exactement oui Gill alors il faut dire
aussi que cette loi elle est extrêmement
compliquée par rapport au mineurs parce
que là on en parle quand on arrive en
France avant l'âge de 13 ans Cyril on
bénéficie de quelque chose qui s'appelle
la protection quasi absolue c'est-à-dire
qu'on considère que si vous êtes en
France avant 13 ans ben vous êtes
quasiment inexpulsable sauf si vous
portez atteintte gravement aux intérêts
de la nation et cetera quand il a été
contrôlé l'agresseur la darace le jeudi
ils n'avait pas d'armes donc ils l'ont
contrôlé la veille du drame ils l'ont
contrôlé mais il y a pas eu de procédure
parce qu'il y avait pas d'intraction
c'est incroyable ils avaient contrôlé la
téléphonie aussi comme il y avait rien
sur la téléphonie euh voilà s'est passé
aussiut autre chose euh il y a il y a il
y a une autre personne qui a été
interpellé ailleurs qui avé un couteau
mais il n'a pas commis il n'a pas eu le
temps de commettre d'infraction et
apparemment Gill est-ce que c'est vrai
que cette personne serait juste jugée
pour détention d'armes oua dans les
évelines parce que racontez-nous cette
histoire parce que pour les
téléspectateurs je crois dans les évines
à Limet peut-être bien voilà donc
quelqu'un qui était aux abords d'un
établissement avec une arme mais en
France quand il y a pas de délit commis
la simple potentialité que vous
commettiez un délit s'il y a pas des
bases strictes de la téléph
c'est alors qu'il étaitouterme si je dis
pas de B oui alors qu'il était sans
doute en train de songer à commettre un
attentat c'est incroyable le cœur du
débat il est vraiment là c'està-dire que
nos services de renseignement on s'en
aperçoit affaire après affaire ils ont
les éléments ils ont les personnes elles
sont fich elles sont connues elles sont
sont contrôlé donc c'est pas le problème
les services de renseignement fonction
bien mais on n'arrive pas à éviter le
passage à l'acte c'est ce que dit le
ministre de l'Intérieur notamment parce
que le soupçon ne suffit pas aujourd'hui
il faut avoir un élément dans le casier
judiciaire pour pouvoir expulser
quelqu'un ou en tous les cas pour
pouvoir demander au préfet de de le
faire justement là il va être jugé
pourquoi on m'a dit on m'a dit qu'il
avait quand même il avait pas des vidéos
aussi bizar oui av avait des photos de
décapitation oui mais ça je comprends
pas moi excusez-moi je pose la question
il est 19h48 mon direct merci d'être
avec nous un gars est arrêté aux abords
d'un établissement scolaire avec un
couteau il a dans son téléphone des
photos de décapitation et ça passe et on
l'a juste là il va prendre que 6 mois
apparemment parce que il il va juste
être jugé pour détention
d'armes écoutez vous trouvez ça
normal s'il y a pas apologie du
terrorisme s'il y a pas il av il avait
consulté des sites antisémite il a pas
longt donc il avait il avait quand même
un
dossierif oui mais bon mais je je suis
d'accord avec vous que ça pose un vrai
problème parce que cette
personnel j'espère que non et que je dis
n'importe quoi mais j'espère que ça fera
pas comme celui qui est passé à l'action
à haras et dont on savait qu'il était
radicalisé et dangereux par que lui il
va sortir dans 6 mois he c'est ça et que
voilà c'est ça c'est ça fauti il va
sortir dans 6 mois 6 mois c'est
rienz raison et dans le casaras c'est
ils sont suivis depuis longtemps puisque
l'affaire dure depuis 2014 le frère est
impliqué dans une tentative d'attentat
contre contre
et il aurait communiqué avec l'auteur
des faits donc je veux dire tous ces
faitsl sont connus ils sont suivis il y
a des éléments qui sont assez mais mais
vous croyez quoi vous croyez que la
police vous croyez quoi les gars cyez
ils ont ils ont ils ont chopé ce gars
pour en vrai c'est extraordinaire bravo
à eux bravo à eux et qu'est-ce qu'ils se
disent ils disent on va le mettre au
trou dans 6 mois il est dehors non mais
vous rendez compte ou pas donc on va
aller devoir rechercher le même gars et
donc il faudrait qu'on attrape le gars
quand il a commis un délit grave
juste cout et qu' a des décapitation
danséléphone on dit bon non c'est c'est
pas sûr me c'est toute la difficulté de
la non commission des faits
ou non mais nous on est un merveilleux
pays la France on est humaniste on est
accueillant et je pense qu' y a un
moment donné il va falloir que la loi
change et je pense qu'on doit être
beaucoup plus ferme face à cette menace
malgré tout et ces attentats islamistes
qui sont juste insupportables d'abord il
faut les nommer parce que la France
insoumise ne les nomme jamais c'est
comme des gros mots pour eux à chaque
fois je regardais encore ce weekend par
rapport à à ce pauvre professeur il y en
a pas un à pas un je vous dis bien à
part Raquel garido qui a proncé le mot
d'islamiste à part rel garido est en
train de se se un se sortir se
désolidarise de la FR elle a bien raison
àelle elle mérite mux il faut qu'elle
arrête avec S et et et je trouve que
malgré tout il y a aussi un laxisme par
exemple par rapport aux TF quand on sait
que par exemple il y a le droit d'avoir
12 recours c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont le
droit 12 fois de redemander la
possibilité de rester en France donc on
vous dit non tu dois partir recours non
tu dois partir recours non tu dois
partir 12 fois d'affilé donc en fait
c'est c'est impossible c'està dire qu'on
marche sur la tête on est une démocratie
mais face à voilà face à des mouvements
comme ça on doit être beaucoup plus
ferme et beaucoup plus autoritaires il y
a Camille un pote qui me dit il doit y
avoir une condamnation ultra lourde pour
terrorisme il a il a rien bah oui ouii
ah oui non il a raison oui non mais les
chiffres sont assez hallucinants parce
que il y a 100 % des attentats
meurtriers qui ont été perprétés par des
terroristes qui sont connus des services
de police ou des renseignements et il y
a 60 % qui étaient fich S et il y a que
7 % des otf qui sont réalisé en France
donc c'est rien du tout 7 % c'est c'est
zé enfin c'est que d alors euh